deliberately engineering a volcanic
system what would we actually like to
[Music]
do maybe I should first start with the
question how do volcanoes actually work
because um when I started hanging out
with actra geologist I realized that my
child would understand Volcan was
totally wrong the as a kid I had this
idea that the Earth is full of really
hot magma and it really wants to get out
it's under high pressure and if you get
a ho it's going to Fountain out and you
get volcano I think that is how we often
think about it and it's obviously wrong
if you think a little bit more about it
why why would the volcano ever stop
shouldn't that magma just keep on going
forever until all of Earth was covered
magma it doesn't work like that what's
actually going on is of course that
Earth is full of magma and light parts
of the magma tend to flow to the top
light stuff like the Rocks we're
standing on the the limestones under us
and even the granite of the Scandinavian
Shield they're pretty light compared to
the contents of Earth so we're floating
to the top and then they get solid and
somewhat brittle and that's how we get
the continental plates moving around now
the interesting thing is these plates
get moved around because of the big
currents inside the earth and quite
often they get to an edge where they
start one of them starts subducting they
go on the Val one what happens there
well usually that on the sea Flor so you
get a lot of sand and Limestone and
other and stuff being dragged slowly
very very very slowly Into the Depths
and compressed and it's of course full
of water and other interesting things
eventually that starts melting and
transforming sometimes it just turns
into limestone sometimes that Limestone
gets heat up more and we might get
marbles sometimes it melts completely
and just dissolves but you also have a
ridiculous amount of water in normal
Rock one of the best science exhibits I
ever seen is in the Smithsonian museum
in Washington where they show cubes of
various rocks and beakers filled with
water showing how much water VAR is and
normal granite and one liter of granite
has a few deciliter of water which of
course if that is a super hot molten
that water really really wants to get
out it wants to be steam except that
it's under pressure of kilometers of
rock on top of it but you get this
interesting lubricating effect as the
plate descends into the depth you get
light stuff that wants to Bubble Up and
that's usually where you have a
subduction zone like for example outside
the Japanese Islands a bit on the other
side you get volcanos where stuff
bubbles up from the dissolving plate
this is why you get the dramatic
volcanoes in the andian mountains part
of an Pacific Plate goes down Into the
Depths and then you get these bubbles
this is one way you get these volcano
you can also have a hot spot where some
really hot magma is going up from the
core of the earth and coming up under
the plate we see that in Hawaii we get
Blobs of magma popping up creating the
volcanoes and creating this chain of
islands and as the plate is slowly
moving across it you get new islands
forming so right now Hawaii the main
island is the biggest one and the older
ones are less volcanically active and
they slowly get the roaded away
eventually get to the Midway Islands and
then a bunch of
reefs now what happens inside the
volcano you have this blobe of lighter
stuff it wants to get up but there's a
lot of hard stuff on top of it sometimes
it can melt its way and up and you get
cracks and eventually of course and you
get to a situation where pressure gets
lowered at which point of course we get
this
phenomenon because you have a lot of gas
and water dissolve okay that wasn't as
dramatic this was yeah
there is a scale for the the size of
eruptions the volcanic eruption index
and that one is probably minus 10 on the
scale or
something
now what happens is basically that once
the pressure gets low enough then you
can get that a lot of the gases and
water start boiling off and of course
it's just like when a Coke to some
extented it drags a lot of the lava with
it and now it's bubbling up now you can
have lavas that are very fluid like on
Hawaii they don't contain that much
gases they still produce some rather
nice fluffy rocks but they generally
just pour out and you get a very nice
wide volcano you can also have stuff
that is much stickier much more like
taffy especially if it's a lot of quartz
in it which has a low melting point but
it's also kind of got a bit of tensile
strength at that point it can become
much more sou and you get a proper penan
eruption named after the pl
the Elder who did some Inu studies on
Theus as it was erupting and giving us a
beautiful description of what was going
on and then dying of course because it's
not a good thing to be a fat old Roman
general with asthma when you're
encountering a lot of volcanic
gases but yeah we named at least named
that form of eruption after him so yeah
he he would probably be rather proud of
that now that kind of explosive eruption
can get even worse if there is a lot of
water in the ground that gets boiled
underneath then you get a so-called ftic
eruption that can get very dramatic okay
so now I've been talking far too much
about rocks and volcano mechanics what
can we do about this well one
interesting thing is that people have
been thinking about messing with
volcanoes for quite some time so the
most obvious thing is can we stop them
from erupting and besides trying to
appeasing the gods you can of course try
bombing the volcanoes this is a very
American thing
so the first test was actually in 1935
when Mount aloa had a big eruption and
the lava stream was headed towards Hilo
the big city on the big island and
especially it's water supply that would
be bad so they were wondering maybe we
could stop this so they asked maybe you
in the Air Force could bomb it so they
sent up a few bip planes and started
bombing by the way the guy that did that
was to become a general by name of
George S Patton who apparently made a
name of himself a bit later in some
War now the interesting thing is they
bmed it and then it the lava flow
actually didn't go much further which
probably was because the eruption had
stopped nobody really believed that
actually stopped it uh but people have
been trying this and especially around
Hawaii it seems to be that the Air Force
have been trying to bomb lava flows a
number of times sometimes it going in
lava tunnels so which means that you
insulate the lava quite well and it can
flow a long distance so maybe if you can
break the top of that that means that it
cools down and stops flowing doesn't
seem to work that well but people have
been trying that um you can also maybe
try to bump things so you get a crater
and get it to turn away from the city or
the your favorite Orchid Plantation
again tricky uh on Etna which has been
kind of an unruly volcano for a long
time they tried this in 83 and it didn't
work that well they were starting to try
to build walls that worked better
eventually they actually succeeded in
redirecting a lava flow but that was was
by actually sending people close to it
and digging some holes and putting about
500 kilos of dynamite into it running
off and exploding it that manual work
actually did redirect the lava flow in a
good manner but it takes some rather
brave
people so so generally it seems like
that kind of messing with volcanoes it
kind of works but it's hard to get to to
work and it's not that dramatic on the
other hand people have accidentally
drilled into magma Chambers and the
reason for that is new geothermal so
traditional geothermal energy you drill
down a hole you send down water it gets
heated up by the heat in the Earth's
crust is not that effective because the
temperature difference between the
Surface and the deep down is not that
big at least in places like the UK in
Iceland of course you can get much
bigger temperature differences much
better efficiency but what if you dig
down really deep and maybe Frack the the
ground that is new geothermal and thanks
to fracking we're actually getting much
better green energy this way because you
can actually get much more power even in
places like the UK by doing this but of
course you can get even more heat if you
do this very close to a volcano so
people have been doing that for example
Hawaii and accidentally oops there we
got into the magma chamber this has also
happened
in I can't pronounce that over in Kenya
and in cwla in Iceland in the all these
cases the main effect was you lost your
drill and then some yeah yeah and then
uh magma poured up but you have a hole
that has been kind of cooled because you
generally want to cool down your drill
anyway so it just freezes into obsidian
or uh other minerals so you basically
get the whole full and stuck in one of
the cases actually got a little squirt
of magma pouring out and of course
Icelandic people being Icelandic people
will say hey cool let's try to do this
deliberately so there is the crafa magma
Observatory that is now actually
deliberately trying to drill down and
see what we can see down
there now this was mostly accident but
it might be much more of that in the
future why well geal energy is a big
deal and also that really hot water that
water that desperately wants to they
become Steam and get away it's also very
good at dissolving minerals there is a
reason why you find gold in remnants of
old volcanic systems because some metals
and some other substance that are easy
to dissolve at high temperature in super
and heated water tend to follow it so if
you could tap that you can get
interesting things in particular people
are interested in lithium so there is
some serious thinking about using
geothermal sources to get lithium out of
the ground which is useful for Batteries
but there might be gold and other things
that you might really really want to get
so given this I was talking to Laura and
she agreed that yeah people are totally
going to be messing around with
volcanoes in the future that seems to
suggest that maybe we should think about
volcano engineering as an actual thing
and start thinking about what is the
eics when is this a good idea and when
is it a bad idea and the how far should
we run in that
case um now the interesting part here is
if you think about deliberately
engineering a volcanic system what would
we actually like to do so I mentioned
some of it but you can imagine both
mitigate eruptions making sure the lava
flows go in a in a different direction
or maybe having a big explosion go away
from the city Robin towards the city but
the dream would of course be maybe to
stop eruptions from happening or maybe
even trigger them uh so in a hilarious
article in Popular Mechanics from 1944
Harold o whitel apparently a professor
of ology at the time he wrote this
article and this titled let us blast
Japan from
below yep he was happily suggesting but
maybe we should send bombers and bomb
the Japanese volcanoes so they all erupt
and that's going to force the Japanese
to give up yeah it was a stupid idea on
a lot of different levels partially of
course as I explained earlier just
because you blow up at the top of a
volcanic Mountain doesn't mean that you
have a magma underneath that will
immediately and happily erupt
and you might get it in the wrong places
and um there is also that little thing
about H this might actually have been a
war crime even by the standards of
1944 the I'm going to get back to that
so this was mostly an interesting
exciting article for the boys to read in
Popular Mechanics nothing came of it
unfortunately and as far as I know
nobody has ever seriously been trying to
use volcanic Warfare ever
since another interesting thing that was
suggested
was maybe this is a good way of reducing
carbon dioxide emissions after all
volcanoes produce a lot of carbon
dioxide it turns out that there is a
problem and that is we humas are right
now producing about 40 times more so
this would be good for the carbon budget
if it could turn off the volcanoes but
it wouldn't exactly get us off the hook
it might still be a good thing to be
aware of especially if in the future we
turn totally carbon neutral or very
carbon negative we might want to turn
off volcanoes too um another interesting
thing is of course if you have really
cheap geothermal energy you can you even
if you can't transport it long distance
you might use that to run something that
sequesters carbon and put it in the
ground probably far away from the
volcano one reason why those Siberian
trap volcanoes were so bad for the world
was that apparently they erupted through
various carbon bents so they they
released also a lot of carbon dioxide
besides the usual other volcanic
contents
now the really interesting thing here is
that digging into volcanoes to get the
pyroclastic flow when they explode or
lava to go somewhere that's one approach
another thing people have already done
is draining Crater Lakes quite a lot of
volcanoes have a lake in the crate there
where water accumulates and quite often
carbon dioxide and other gases Bubble Up
from the below so the lake water is full
of exciting chemicals and can be really
carbonated which sometimes mean that
it's start bubbling and fishing and that
releases more carbon dioxide and
suddenly you get a cloud of carbon
dioxide quite often mixed with other
lovely sulfur compounds and other
noxious things that pour down the side
of the mountain and this can lead to
asfixiation and and local disasters
people have done some experiment in
creat lakes in Cameroon where you put in
a pipe and essentially try to boil off
the carbon dioxide in a controlled
manner it's worked once or twice it we
still don't know how to do it well but
it looks like it's a plausible to do the
thing that got me really excited is a
paper by Will Cox and others from 2015
about how to diffuse the Yellow Stone
super
volcano so how do you do it the answer
is green energy you you want to remove a
lot of heat from that enormous blob of
magma under Yellowstone so you around
the edge you start putting a lot of
hydral plants but pump in cold water and
get very hot steam out and now you're
getting free in the green energy and
then you do is around you don't want to
do it in the middle because you don't
want the lid to get too fragile and to
crack that might be a bad thing you
really want to do it in the right spots
around the rim and slowly slowly leech
all the heat out of this big Big Blob of
magma faster than it's accumulating heat
from the interior of Earth and the cool
thing is it looks like if you build
build 16 gwatt of geothermal plants you
can actually do this it only takes
16,000
years now it's kind of an interesting
project because in some sense okay this
takes 16,000 years to do in the meantime
we're getting free green energy and the
typical time between super eruptions is
about 100,000 years so actually this
reduces the risk to North America quite
significantly on the other hand getting
a politician to sign off on this project
is kind of an interesting challenge we
need to think think carefully about how
we sell this also uh maybe Wyoming and
Montana are not exactly hot beds of
energy intensive industry right now so
we might need to send the energy
somewhere else or maybe this is where
you want to build your greenberry energy
intensive Industries maybe you want to
run the data centers to mine a lot of
Bitcoin or
whatever to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas